what if all the ice in the world acted
like this
this is sodium acetate also known as hot
ice it's the same thing that's used in
chemical heating packs and can make
these Cool Ice Crystal formations so
although it's not technically ice it
does look like it but it's also hot to
the touch so what would happen if we
replaced our ice with it well the first
thing you'd notice would be that all the
animals living in the Arctic would
migrate down south this is because the
Arctic would become extremely hot and
all the new hot ice in it would burn
anyone who touched it but what if all
this hot ice suddenly melts well then
all the chemicals from the hot ice would
go into our oceans and make them toxic
you wouldn't want to drink or eat any of
this stuff either if you consumed enough
of it you'd get sick and die so although
this could make it possible the
snowboard in your bathing suit it
wouldn't be worth it